it has been a rough 24 hours for
president biden yesterday the supreme
court blocked his vaccine mandate for
large businesses and two senators from
his own party dealt a blow to his
efforts to pass voting rights
legislation nancy cordes is following
all of it from the white house for us
nancy good morning to you
good morning and even before yesterday's
news this had been a rough week for the
white house with the u.s setting new
global records for covid cases and
hitting a 40-year high for inflation but
then yesterday dealt what could be fatal
blows to a pair of big biden initiatives
the honest-to-god answer is i don't know
whether we can get this done if
president biden sounded exasperated
thursday it's no wonder setbacks came
from every direction
i know we're all frustrated as we enter
this new year it started with voting
rights the president made his case in
person on capitol hill and yet two
moderate democrats remained unmoved
refusing to support a change to senate
rules that would make it easier for
democrats to pass major voting reform
that republicans oppose arizona's
kirsten cinema is one of the two
democratic holdouts i will not support
separate actions that worsen the
underlying disease of division infecting
our country the next blow came from the
supreme court which struck down the
administration's new osha rule requiring
workers at large companies to either get
vaccinated or get routinely tested
in a 6-3 decision the court's
conservative majority wrote that the
osha rule is a significant encroachment
into the lives and health of a vast
number of employees
and they said covet is not an
occupational hazard in most businesses
it's a big loss for president biden
republicans cheered to me the mandate
was a massive overreach by the
government we're going to have to
determine what the next steps are white
house press secretary jensachi was asked
repeatedly thursday about all the bad
news our effort is to do hard things try
hard things and keep at it we could
certainly propose legislation to see if
people
support bunny rapids and ice cream but
that wouldn't be very rewarding to the
american people so the president's view
is we're going to keep pushing for hard
things to that end mr biden met again
last night with the two democrats
blocking his agenda and he vowed to keep
fighting for voting rights despite the
grim prospects if we missed the first
time
we could come back and try it a second
time
it wasn't all bad news for this white
house yesterday the supreme court did
uphold a new federal rule requiring
vaccinations in many medical settings
and the white house was able to announce
that it has procured 380 million covid
tests to be delivered for free to
americans across the country still this
is the kind of day that many white house
officials are probably waking up and
saying
thank goodness it's friday
tough road ahead for the president nancy
thank you very much as always appreciate
it